Hi everyone, um, thanks for coming.
Uh, my name is Rick Oaks, and
I have, uh, a, a few other people here with
me to help present this session, COP 202,
what's new in AWBS optimization.
Uh, I lead the product management team for
AWBS optimization tools
including compute optimizer,
uh, cost optimization hub, savings plan
analyzer,
savings plan recommendations, and I
know I'm probably missing some.
Um, and I also sit on the Finops Foundation Technical
Advisory Council helping AWS represent
how customers optimize and operate with,
uh, financial management.
Bonnie, Bonnie Fernstall, I lead
Delta Airlines, uh, central Finops team.
Mary Naimov, I lead the savings plan
purchase experience.
Thank you. All right, so, um,
we, we have a lot of stuff to get through today and we're really
excited to have you all here.
Just before we dive into any sort of specific
content, I'm curious how many of you folks are
here from FinOps
organizations? Show of hands.
Awesome, that's great.
How many are maybe more FinOs adjacent,
maybe engineering leaders or engineering folks?
OK, so it's about actually fairly split.
That's awesome.
Um, OK, so
how many of you have,
before I dive into specific features and announcements,
how many of you have used some of our AWS
optimization tooling such as compute
optimizer?
Awesome, that's great to see. OK, we've
got some new things in compute optimizer to show you.
How many of you have made savings plan
purchases with our recommendations or analyzer
tooling? Wow, we've
got a lot of optimization aficionados
in the crowd. Cool. OK, so
first on the agenda we've got, we've got
some new features that we'll talk about,
um. We're gonna talk first
about EBS optimization. How
many of you heard of this new launch? We just launched it about a
week ago,
right before Thanksgiving.
No, OK, you're gonna love it. So in
compute optimizer we offer recommendations
for those of you that haven't used it yet,
recommendations for right sizing, modernization,
idle detection, and clean up
for things like EC2, EBS, RDS,
and quite a few other services.
Inside Compute optimizer, we kept hearing from
customers, I like these recommendations,
but there's so many of them. You keep giving me
more, it's really hard to
get after the ones I already have, and you keep
launching more, so help us take them.
Uh, and it's great feedback. We love building and launching
new capability here, so
optimization has been pretty high on our priority
list for a while now.
We decided to focus on
the low hanging fruit, easy to do optimizations
to get started here. In this case, EBS
idle cleanup, which is
EBS volumes that are unattached
to any instance
and are really not adding any value to
your environment.
Uh, so we have optimization that will automatically
snapshot those unattached volumes
and delete them for you
and maybe even add tags if you wish as well.
We also will automate the
upgrade of volumes, and that means moving
from GP2 to GP 3 for a 20%
cost improvement
or moving from IO1 to IO2
for resiliency improvements.
And so this optimization capability
allows you to apply these recommendations
in your environment automatically.
You can apply them immediately
by selecting them and hitting execute or
implement,
or you can create a policy
which will allow you to schedule the cleanups
and do it repeatedly over time to keep
your environment clean.
We're really excited about this because
as we were talking to customers there's
a lot of these volumes to go clean up
and we understand that the scale problem
took a lot of time from FinOps teams
and engineering teams and so this will allow
you to set up these automation rules and
move on to other more interesting or
impactful things where cleaning up storage
volumes isn't always the most fun and engaging.
So A little bit more details.
Here's a screenshot of our console. I'll
also go through a demo here in a minute.
Uh, you'll be able to see the recommendations that
are applicable for automation. You
can multi-select and click
the little review and apply button right there in the top
and save money immediately. And I
hope before
the end of the week maybe open up your laptop, take a
look at this, maybe try a few and
start saving money right away. My hope is that
at the end of reinvent you've all saved a little bit of money
with these optimization tools.
You can also create
these automation rules.
Now automation rules
are very flexible. You can
create an automation rule for your entire
payer account and organization.
You can create an automation rule for a
subset of accounts, say non-production
with different rules or configurations
or maybe an individual linked account as well,
so you can kind of scope out and figure
out. What specific
scope or organization or team
is is OK with execution
of automation
of recommendations and create rules
just for them.
You can also add criteria
to the automation.
If you, how many of you have
tags
for environment like production and
non-production and.
These very envi environment variables
awesome. So if you want,
you can create an automation rule that
applies only to certain tag combinations,
and you can even select multiple different
tag combinations
or set rule criteria based on region,
capacity,
or quite a few other options as well.
Lastly, you can set a schedule
if your organization likes to
make changes in your environment in downtime
windows or maintenance windows, you can
select a window for these recommendations
to implement
which allows you to target those maintenance
windows,
uh, even though the recommendations that we
have for you
with automation have no downtime
or no necessary impact,
we understand a lot of organizations still do
have change control windows that they would like to
respect. Lastly,
Once you take the recommendations, do
you have a question? Sure, I'd take a question.
Can you do that
You can do it either across accounts
or in an individual account, and I'll
show that in the demo as well.
Tracking results. Once you have implemented
recommendations, you can look at how many were
implemented and how much savings
that you've accomplished or achieved
from taking these recommendations.
Now this graph is basically
a sum of the monthly
potential savings. We're not tracking it month
over month and accruing it over time. This is
just a very simple sum of that
potential savings metric.
One of the most important
parts of how we automate
optimization
is safety nets.
Engineering teams do not want to get
called at 2 in the morning because of incidents
or outages or issues,
so we've built a lot of these safety nets into
the automation pipeline to help
protect from any sort of impact.
You can roll back any
recommendation that you've implemented
for up to 1 year after
the automation has been implemented.
So because we automatically take
a snapshot of a volume before we make
a change on it.
We have that snapshot available to use
in a rollback event for one year.
We also have other safety nets.
We automatically check if
the reason why the volume was marked
as unattached is still true
before we implement the recommendation.
So there's another safety net, and if it fails
that check
of still being unattached,
then the automation will
be marked as failed,
and
anytime you have a failed automation,
it will make sure to not implement the
recommendation, thereby leaving you in a healthy
state. So
before we get to the next one, I'm going to switch over here
to my laptop and we're going to demo this automation
feature. So
those of you familiar with compute optimizer,
should be
a screen that you're used to and
The new thing here is on the left side of the
screen you'll see an automation section.
Um, I'm going to go ahead and click on recommended
actions. These are the recommendations that are
eligible for automation.
In this case, we have two recommendation types
snapshot and delete unattached EBS volumes
and upgrade EBS volumes.
In this case, I have some GP2 to GP
3 volumes that need to be upgraded,
and I can see the estimated savings for each
one of these,
and I can see exactly what recommendation type.
I have,
I can multi-select some of these recommendations,
and at the top of the screen it'll tell me how much money
I'll save per month by taking these recommendations
and I can click review and apply
so you can save money that quickly. How,
how many clicks was that? Like 45?
So the idea here is to make optimization
very easy for everybody to implement.
And if you have some
environments that just have a lot of
aged EBS volumes and you want to just
clean them up right now, this is a great option.
If you have a lot of accounts where
you want automated or recurring
uh implementation of automation,
you can create an automation rule.
Now you can create an automation rule at
the organization level or at a linked
account level
and you get to choose which ones
get implemented first
so you can kind of set priorities here
on if you want an individual team to
run their own automation or if you,
if maybe you have a central fin ops team
that manages optimization for everybody.
You'll have the ability to
have sort of organizational level
automation rules.
Uh, let's save questions to the end. Thank you.
Um, so
once I look at these automation rule options,
I can create this automation rule,
and I'm just going to create an organizational rule
and select my linked account in my org.
And I can choose which recommendation
types I would like to apply
in this policy.
Then I'm going to add some rule criteria.
In this case, we talked about tags.
Let's say I have an environment tag.
And say, I want the value to be
development.
How many of you have.
Had tags where some of them are capitalized
and some of them are lowercase.
OK, a lot of nods. OK, so I'm gonna type in
capital D
development and so you can have multiple
tag values here in your criteria
to catch it all.
And then you can also add additional criteria.
So say if I have
maybe.
Estimated savings or volume type criteria,
you can add that here as well
and really customize your automation
rules.
Uh, there you can do ors by
creating additional criteria and picking tag
again, so you can do and or ors.
Now once you've selected your criteria,
you'll get a refreshable list
of the volumes that match your criteria.
In this case, I actually don't have environment tags, but
you'll see the list of all of the volumes
that apply to the criteria that you've selected
and the estimated savings for
those recommendations,
and then you can set your schedule.
In this case you can set midnight on Saturday
or something like that and you can set it to
run for however many hours you have your
window. Note 100
recommendations will be implemented at a time,
and they can take
a variable amount of time depending on the size of the
volume. So just note if you have a lot of very
large volumes, they'll be a little bit slower to
implement.
And implementation will stop
beginning as soon as the window completes.
You can also
add new tags
to the newly changed resources,
so this is great because you can tag something as
optimized. I've already optimized it,
and this allows you to understand how many
resources you've optimized later on or
use those tags for other FinOs purposes.
You name your rule
and then you can set the rule as active or inactive
if you'd like to save it for later
and once you
implement this group.
You'll be able to go into computer optimizer
automation events
and look at the historical number
of recommendations implemented and the
amount of savings.
You'll see any recommendations that completed
or if they failed and then rolled back,
and you can see those by month
and then you can see the savings by month as well.
So that's automation.
If you have any questions on this feature, we will definitely
be available after the session to answer questions.
We also have a blog post and a lot
of great content online to help.
Next up,
we have a new recommendation for you in compute optimizer.
How many of you have not gain
weight usage in your environment?
OK,
Understanding if a NAT gateway is
being well utilized or not is a
complex task.
One of the things that we understand is a lot of customers
run NAT gateways, but they're designed to be
failover or backup NA gateways
in case something happens.
So we designed a new
recommendation to detect idle nat gateways,
and we look at 30 days of historical utilization.
And we also look at if
the net gateway is referenced
in a route table
or associated with the route table.
What that means is we check to see if
it's a failover or backup,
not just if it has zero utilization.
This means we know that there's no route
table association and there's no usage, so
this is a great opportunity for you to talk to the
network team and go figure out if this net gateway
is left behind
and really need it or not.
Once you view
uh Nat gateway recommendation and compute optimizer,
you'll see them populate in the idle recommendation
list, and then you will be
able to click into it and see the utilization
details that validates that this Nat gateway
is not being consumed
and may be an option for you to clean up.
Next up,
cloud optimization efficiency.
We in the cost optimization hub
launched a brand new metric that we're really excited
about. We
heard from a lot of customers that there's
not very many metrics or KPIs
for optimization success
in the FinO space. We have a lot of cost visibility
KPIs, but the optimization
space is kind of lagged behind on a maturity curve
a little bit.
There are some metrics that we've heard from customers
like effective savings rate,
average CPU utilization. But they only
show part of the puzzle.
Effective savings rate, if you optimize it very
well,
will push commitments really high, but
then maybe block you from right sizing or cleaning up
idle.
The same with resource optimization.
If you only optimize resources, you may be leaving
commitments on the table.
So we wanted to come up with a new metric that
equally measures and balances the value
of right sizing and resource optimization
with commitment optimization.
We heard from a lot of customers that they've tried
to make metrics on their own,
convincing leadership of the value of the metrics
and coming to a common agreement on the
definition is very challenging.
So we wanted to
make an attempt at this, so
we created the cost efficiency metric in
the cost optimization hub product.
This is available today for you. We launched it about a
week and a half ago.
And this metric is automatically generated and
populated
with 90 days of daily historical
granularity in cost optimization hub.
This will allow you to set targets and
benchmark your cost efficiency over time
and ideally save more,
more money by helping convince leadership that
efficiency is a very important investment
for your organization.
Here's what it looks like.
In the cost optimization hub you'll see a brand
new graph on the right side. It is your
cost efficiency.
In this case, my environment is very inefficient
because it's a demo account.
You'll see it trended over 90 days, so
you can see.
As you're building new resources, are they efficient
and effective,
or
maybe new resources are not
so efficient and you're seeing the number drop?
This is a great way to talk to individual
resource owners or account owners.
Maybe some resource and account owners have
really great efficiency and maybe have some
stories to tell about how they were able to do that
and you can do a little bit of culture work and knowledge
sharing with teams that are really good at optimization
with teams that maybe need more help.
So let's talk a little bit about how efficiency metric
works.
We take the total potential savings
of all of our recommendations in cost optimization
hub, compute optimizer recommendations,
right size, idol,
RI savings plan recommendations.
We combine them all together.
We deduplicate the savings
so we don't overstate savings, meaning
if there's a bunch of idle resources we won't
tell you to buy a savings plan for them, for example,
we take that number
and we divide it by the total potential
optimizable spend. What that means
is. We take some things out of this number like
credits,
fees,
support costs, things that we can't optimize,
so we have a more stable baseline amount
of spend that is optimizable that we
provide recommendations for.
Then we divide one by 2 and
we have a percentage.
In this case, if you have
maybe $10,000 of potential savings
on an account with $100,000 of
optimizable spend, your efficiency is 90%.
The idea is to make this very easy
to explain to leadership,
and every single individual percentage
point of efficiency relates
to a real dollar value that
is on your invoice,
so driving this metric up will be an
actual real business impact
to your cost.
You will be able to look at the metric by
account,
by region.
And you can look at top 5 highest
efficiency,
lowest 5 efficiency,
and again you could look at specific date
ranges as well if you had
very specific moments in time
where a savings plan expired or you
bought a new savings plan
and your efficiency took a drastic change, you'll
be able to zoom in on that and understand
how are the activities you're doing today
in your FinOs practice will
influence your overall efficiency.
Thank you all so much. I'm going to invite,
uh, Bonnie up from Delta to
tell her story about how they use compute
optimizer to optimize their estate,
and, uh, I really appreciate
all you attending. If you have questions on
these new features, we'll be available afterwards.
Thanks, Bonnie.
Thanks so muchtric.
You know, personally, I'm most excited about
the efficiency metric. It had been part of
my 2026 roadmap,
so I've got one done now, right?
So when I stepped into my role, Delta
was about 3 years into a massive cloud migration
program. An early FinOs practice
had been established, mostly focused on
show back with a little bit of purchase commitment
as well.
Fin-Os became a hot topic for us for
the same reason I imagine it has for most of you.
Our cloud bill is growing rapidly,
and we need levers to pull to rein it in.
Now at this point, all of my FinOps
knowledge came from a web search I did prior
to accepting my position.
So I had no idea what those levers would be.
Luckily for me, compute optimizer had a
set ready to go.
Getting people to adopt those optimizations
in an organization our size
has definitely been a journey.
We learned a lot about the gap between intent
and reality.
Turned to automation to help along the way,
and ultimately ended up achieving measurable
change.
So today I'll share a little bit of that journey with you.
I'm a product person by trade,
so when I first saw the recommendations,
to me it looked like a large number of stories
that needed to be written,
refined,
assigned,
and worked by a large number of teams.
Those stories and the desire to reduce our cloud
costs predated me,
so it was pretty obvious that my job was to
figure out how to turn those opportunities
into reality.
So I started, as I think a lot of people with my
background would,
with the five W's.
Where were people supposed to be picking up the work
from? Developers log
into their accounts daily,
but the people managing the backlogs don't,
and they need a central place to go
to see all the recommendations across
the 1200 account ecosystem we have.
Who is supposed to be performing the work?
If we're gonna ask these busy teams to
put even more work into their backlogs,
we couldn't be asking them to also figure out which
work was theirs,
nor could we establish any sort of accountability
mechanisms without that information.
What was the work?
I went in with the assumption that even though I
may not personally understand the optimization
opportunity,
the teams performing the work would.
But as I mentioned, we're in the middle of a migration journey,
and for many of our developers, the clock was
just as new to them as it was to me.
When was the work going to get done?
As an organization, we had quite a few priorities,
and we're going to have to figure out how to get the visibility
to move up the ladder if we wanted the work to get
done. And
then finally, why?
The work was there,
the desire was there.
So why wasn't it getting done?
This probably sounds pretty familiar as I
found it echoes some of the key findings in
the 2025 State of FinOs report
by the FinOsS Foundation.
Competing priorities,
lack of accountability, and lack of
understanding
are challenges that a lot of us are facing.
We decided to start by tackling where
and who through the creation of the opportunity dashboard.
The recommendations are centralized in a single
database
and then enriched with organizational context
like leader or application name
to provide clear lines of ownership.
Then the report's broken down into two levels.
The summary report lets you view
across both teams and opportunities
where the greatest savings lie.
So whether you own a single application or
an entire development organization,
you can quickly filter and see where your team's
efforts can best be spent.
Then each opportunity has a detailed
report.
And that's really more relevant to the people
performing the work.
You can see at a resource level things like
what account the resources in,
what the actual savings estimate for that particular
resource is,
and usage metrics that can be helpful in
understanding why the recommendation was made.
Than to help with the understanding of what.
Each opportunity has its own opportunity
run book.
This Rum book takes in a 5 minute or
less read,
all of the essential points that you need to
understand, validate, and
implement an opportunity.
This is to help with capacity constraints.
The FinOps team has the time and frankly
the mandate to go deep dive into these opportunities
and understand what they are and their implications.
So by consolidating that information into
a Cliff Notes version,
you can enable your developers to spend less time
reading
and more time optimizing.
I'm gonna pause here and touch on our tagging
strategy.
While I can't take any credit for it,
I think it's really lightweight from a maintenance
perspective
and results in a high quality of data, so it's
worth a mention.
Instead of requiring teams to maintain a bunch
of tags on each resource,
we use a 10 character code and a primary
key that represents the business
capability the technology supports.
The reason this works so well is that while the
exact functionality
or the ownership is likely to change over time,
that core business capability
generally does not.
Each code gets registered in a central architecture
repository,
so teams have a single place to go
to keep the contextual information that we're
so reliant on
up to date.
So I
don't know if any of you have experienced what I did.
We have foundational reporting now where you can
go into a room of leaders
and talk about the savings opportunities you've found
and watch the dollars roll off the cloud
bill in their eyes.
It's fantastic
until you realize that not all opportunities
can be turned into savings.
Early on, I had to roll back some pretty
big numbers I'd reported on
after the teams told me that the opportunities
wouldn't stay valid for long
due to upcoming changes in usage patterns.
Now there was nothing wrong with the recommendation, it
was accurate.
So the key learning here
is that teams have critical information
about plane changes, about their roadmaps,
and if you want to present an accurate picture of
savings,
you have to incorporate that.
So with that, our dashboard changed
from purely a reporting mechanism.
To also incorporate a decision from the teams.
Were they going to implement
or reject an opportunity?
Or did they need to test in a lower environment
prior to deciding?
If they chose to reject it, they also had
to provide a justification,
and that was to allow us a starting point for
conversations later
if teams were rejecting opportunities that
stayed valid,
maybe just based on a lack of understanding.
So with this information
you can now go in and talk about the savings
that your teams have said they will implement.
I did that.
And then I went in the next month,
and the next month,
and talked about many of the same opportunities
and many of the same numbers.
And our leaders started asking one of the same questions
I started with,
when is this going to happen?
That led us to add our final 2 decision
points.
A timeline for implementation.
And then a reason for delay
if the recommendation was expected to stay idle
for more than 30 days.
Now you have a system that provides clear
line of sight into those five W's.
Each week the recommendations get refreshed,
and depending on their change in state, if
they still exist,
they roll up into one of 3 reports.
Unaction opportunities are rolled up by justification
and timeline.
This is to provide insight into the cost
opportunity
of prioritizing other work.
Rejected opportunities going into a validation
report. If teams are
rejecting opportunities that continue
to show up week after week.
There should be a sign off that those are costs that
our organization is willing to carry.
The fun one is implemented opportunities
going to the track savings report.
For this one, we baseline the cost of the
resource the month before the optimization is
performed. And we compare that
to subsequent month costs,
which allows us to
track savings
even if a team's account or environment
or system is still growing.
So what this transparency and the
conversations that we had after it showed to us
was that we had a fundamental misalignment
between team and leader timelines
for implementing these changes.
Leaders want the savings now.
Teams agreed to implement the savings.
But we still had teams migrating workloads.
We still had uh
traffic coming in. The business certainly
hadn't stopped asking for new capabilities,
and teams knew that this was important,
but it just wasn't translating to
those stories getting committed.
So my team turned to automation.
If we knew they're OK with it and they just
couldn't get to it,
we could automate some of that implementation
work and let them focus on those other efforts.
We started at one of the same places the compute optimizer
team did,
cleaning up unattached DBS volumes.
We chose this for a number of reasons.
First, there were 0 autonomy concerns.
We weren't making changes to systems and
there was a broad agreement that no one was
abandoning these volumes on purpose.
2nd was the number of volumes. We
knew this was a place
that we could demonstrate measurable savings,
both in terms of dollar and time.
And then 3rd, we had an on-premise policy
to replicate,
so the behavior wasn't new.
Our flow is pretty much the same as what you saw
and honestly if the automation had existed
back then,
we would have used it rather than build it.
But if you're looking for a place to start,
uh, automating cost optimization,
I highly recommend you check this one out.
Especially with the ability to create snapshots,
though I've yet to hear of a single one being restored,
it's a good way to build trust in automation
and save some money along the way.
We must have been cosmically aligned or something,
because we also looked to volume conversions next.
For us it was mainly IO1 to GP 3.
There was definitely a little bit more concern
here because we're gonna make changes
to the system.
So this required us to do some more
education. We used metrics
to show teams that GP 3 would more than
meet their system requirements in most cases.
And we also had to let people know that not using
GP 3 hadn't been a design decision.
It was new technology. It simply hadn't
existed when they were deploying their systems.
The automation approach is more aligned with that rules-based
approach
in that this automation only runs in
accounts where teams have agreed to opt in.
And it only runs against resources
that teams have agreed to optimize.
This lets teams that are doing all of their updates
through pipeline keep their environments clean.
And ensures that we're aligning with testing timelines
and things like that.
Now the immediate concern here
was that we're going to limit our savings
by allowing teams this latitude.
But that's mostly mitigated by the fact
that the reporting is agnostic of how you
choose to implement.
Whether you solely use automation or
perform every single update yourself,
what's important is that you align with your leader's
timeline for getting the work done.
With this automation for the resources
that it does run against,
after updating the volume directly,
it also loops back and updates
on drifted stacks.
This further helps build buy-in because you're not
creating tech debt for teams to clean up later
and you're also ensuring that it doesn't just pop up on
the report again the next time the system is redeployed.
Finally, we follow everything up with an
email letting teams know what work was
completed
and what work, if any,
remains.
All right, so this set us up to
go after the big one,
Easy to right sizing.
Now, we knew we had to tread carefully
and we had to get this right,
because another team had made an attempt at
right sizing with a different tool's recommendations,
and it was pretty disruptive.
We are confident that we could do this with a compute
optimizer for a couple of reasons.
One was simply the trust that we had built
in this uh both the automation.
And the recommendations in our previous efforts.
And 2 is the ability to customize
those recommendations.
For our first pass, we set the highest threshold
for both CPU
and memory utilization headroom,
letting teams feel comfortable that they had room to
grow. We also excluded
some instance types that weren't compatible
with agents on our base build.
The first run at this was pretty simple. We
looped through the recommendations,
further refine them to low-risk options
with no architectural changes.
Generated an email with an approval link
for the managers.
And then executed approved changes during
our standard change window.
And I think I had about 3 approvals
through the system.
So once again we had to take to the teams
and try to figure out what we were missing.
Getting buy-in for this
required us to adapt to design and resiliency
standards in our org.
This is, uh, this was things like identifying
boxes that needed to be sized identically
for low balancing purposes.
Creating different patterns for different environments
or different resiliency tiers.
And allowing an opt-out option
for teams that maybe have vendor
software that has specific requirements
behind it.
This was definitely a heavier lift,
but what it allowed us to do ultimately
was shift from an opt-in
to an opt-out approach,
providing greater savings.
Now what I haven't stated explicitly, but
I hope you've heard through all this,
is how key communication is.
And I want to stress how critical it is in
this space to establish
and to adhere to a communication pattern.
For us it looks something like this,
in form,
often more than once.
Then open the door for feedback.
Don't go in assuming that you know why an
unoptimized decision was made.
When you do take action,
make sure you're transparent
about what's being done with that feedback.
Teams need to have confidence that you've heard them
and that you understand the potential implications
of whatever decision is finally made.
For our organization, this has also been aided
by the implementation of a cost champion
program. I have a really small team.
There's 4 of us.
And so getting the scale
of work done,
we had each cost center owner
appoint a champion or two.
And we meet with these these people on a
biweekly basis.
We educate them about new opportunities.
We tell them about new processes, change to
reporting,
and more recently, and my favorite is they've
started coming to us
and educating us in the community about optimizations
that they've actually found.
They trust us,
their teams trust their knowledge of their domains,
and those two things combined let us get far
greater reach than we could have on our own.
And
along that journey we've managed to see a
27% monthly cost savings.
Just as important to me, if
maybe not to my boss,
is the cultural transformation that we've achieved
along the way.
Teams as they become more educated about these
optimizations are starting
to shift left and incorporate them in their
design phases.
Which is allowing FinOs to become a part of
how we work,
rather than the extra work it seemed to be
initially.
That partnership is so key
in building trust,
to making that happen, and it ultimately
leads to the teams
being more likely to accept new optimizations
and new automations.
And all of this combined
provides the foundation for our leaders to make
data-driven decisions that thread
the line between cost optimization
and the 100 other priorities that cross their
desks every day.
Now I mentioned at the beginning that we
have some purchase commitments,
but we've kept a modest baseline to this point,
and that's been an intentional strategy.
We didn't want to commit ourselves to resources
that were maybe oversized
or entirely unnecessary.
But now that we're reaching a much better state,
we intend to look to this in 26 as a
big lever to control our costs.
So I wanna invite Mary up onto the stage
to tell us more about the some developments in that
space. Perfect. Thank you,
Bonnie. Thank you so much for the insights and the
stories.
Um,
hi everybody.
Uh, have a key question for you.
What do you do when you have
different types of databases running
across your environment?
You want to optimize your cost
and you want to do it fast.
From this week, you can purchase
a database savings plan.
Uh, thank you.
This is um
one of the most exciting uh launches
we have uh at this reinvent. Uh,
we saw a lot of excitements already in the
news. Um, my name is
Mary Naimov. I lead the savings
plan purchase experience at AWS
and overall, I'm just obsessed
about creating simple experiences
for technical complex products.
Today,
I'm going to show you,
uh,
basically we'll go through an introduction of
what are database savings plans.
Then we'll see how the savings plans will
apply to your database services
usage. And lastly, I'll show
you how to purchase a database savings plan
with our own
native AWS tooling like savings
plan purchase analyzer
and savings plan recommendations.
Uh, can you raise your hand again who used
these tools before?
OK, perfect.
Great. Uh, so you can utilize
your knowledge
to purchase the new database savings plan.
And if you never purchased a database savings
plan, don't worry, after this talk,
you're going to be an expert and you will be able to
teach other people how to purchase a database
savings plan.
OK, so let's start with the basics.
A savings plan is basically a
um a
$1 per hour commitment for a
long-term period.
You can purchase, for example, $1
for 1 year and in exchange for
this long-term commitment,
you will get a discount pricing.
It's the easiest way to start saving
in your AWS environment because it doesn't
require any
Architectural changes and the best part
is after you purchase it, it automatically
applies
to all the eligible usage you have in your
environment. So you don't really have to do
anything after you purchase. You just monitor the success
of that, then you can repurchase more
and more as you have a consistent usage in your
environment. A
little small history
lesson about savings plan.
Today we have all these types in our environment.
We launched Compute and EC2 savings plan
in 2019.
Sagemaker came out in 2021,
and this week,
as I said, we are really proud to
introduce database savings plan of 2025.
The database savings plan gives
you up to 35%
discount. It's
a one year commitment and
it's no upfront cost,
no upfront payment, which means that you're going to
pay for this.
On a monthly basis.
Uh, it's very easy. All this
information is also in the UI,
so you really don't have to memorize it. The
UI will guide you through the purchase experience.
OK, this is one of the key slides that
a lot of our customers are curious about.
What actually the database savings
plan will cover.
So we have 9 types of
database savings plans
services that it will cover like RDS,
Aurora. Dynamo DB elastic cash,
you're welcome to take a picture,
as you can see, the serverless has a
higher type of discount,
so this savings plan is actually encouraging
you to modernize
and move from instances to server-less.
Once you do that.
The savings that you will get from the
same purchase will be actually higher because
it will cover the ser serverless
types. After
you purchase the savings plan, it will
start to apply to your usage.
So in this example, uh, we show
that there is Aurora serverless with 35%
discount, Elastic Cash, and Dynamo
DB. Once you purchase the database
savings plan, it will start to apply
to the
Service with the highest
discount. So in this case, 35%
on serverless Aurora.
Once it applies to that,
it will trickle to Elastic Cash and finally
to Dynamo DB.
In this way, it maximizes
the savings plan you get from the purchase because it
applies to the highest discount first.
When you, OK, so you say I, I
have all these
different services running, how much should I buy?
How should I decide what to buy?
You can start with a conservative purchase of
50% coverage.
It's a great start.
So if you have no savings plan currently
in your environment, you just start with something
and you start covering 50%.
In this case, we're covering
uh most all of the aurora and
most of the elastic cash.
Uh, you can then move on and maximize
your savings. So this is a watermark
line of this is the max
savings you can get from savings from purchases
because if you go above this line.
You actually don't have enough of
on-demand
to justify a savings fun purchase.
That max savings, we actually in our tooling
will help you to find that watermark line
and you can build up to it with small purchases
over time. Or if you have an
environment that is always growing, you can
start from max savings and just keep purchasing
more and more as your usage becomes
consistent.
OK, so lastly, before
we jump to the demo, I want to show you the
um workflow that our customers
do for all their savings plans.
First, you analyze your environment and
you use your recommendation or purchase analyzer
to decide
on which one to purchase.
You add it to the cart with a few clicks
you purchase and then you start monitoring
it with coverage and utilization
reports.
Coverage utilization reports will show
you how much of your on-demand is covered
and how much your savings plan is being utilized
in the environment.
Lastly, after you review your
purchase in the reports, you can
again do the same thing. Use the
tools to analyze a new purchase, repurchase
and just see your coverage grow over time.
With that, I'm really excited to show you a
demo on this topic, so let's
do that. Uh, once
I'm in the billing cost management, I'll scroll
down over here and there's a savings
plan area and we have all
these, uh, pages, overview, inventory
recommendations.
Um, they supported all the savings
plans we had until now and now they support also
database savings plans. So if you use you used
anything like this before,
you can just, uh, um,
continue building upon your knowledge and use the same
tools. I'll start with clicking on
recommendations.
Here I see all the 4 types of savings
plans we have compute,
database,
EC2, and Sage maker.
I'm gonna click on database
and I'm gonna see that it's already selected for me
one year and upfront,
um, so that's the offering as
you can see here,
and I have a selection on based on the past.
So here I need to select the lookback
period that most likely are going
to be reflecting my future
because we're gonna find that max savings
waterline based on the historical
usage patterns.
Let's take a look at what I have for the last
30 days.
So I'm gonna click here on view details
and I'm gonna see a visual chart that
will, we'll go over
and it uh to explain how we found this
max savings number.
So in this case, I see that my recommendation
is $2 per hour
and it will save me around $300.
It's very low.
Um, on in red, it's the on-demand
usage. So you can see that we were
testing this feature before we invent
and we spin up a lot of database services
up and down to see uh that
we, uh, everything is working correctly, so you
can see that usage.
But since I don't have a lot of
things in the last 30 days,
the recommendation is really low because it's targeting
the consistent usage.
So in this case I want to modify it and
that's why uh we have Purchase analyzer.
If I click here, I'm going to Purchase analyzer.
You can also start from Purchase Analyzer
if you scroll down here
and click straight to Purchase Analyzer.
Here you see the same kind of selection.
I have the 4 types of savings plan.
I'm gonna click on database
and I I need to select all
these things here. So
The
analysis level
payer will take all the usage
across all the linked accounts
and we will build a recommendation on top
of that. If you want to focus on one of
the linked accounts, you can also click here
and you will have a linked account selection.
Once you select that, one year, no upfront,
no selection over here.
And here I'm gonna focus on an area
where I had a lot of usage.
It's actually started on the 28th,
where we had
uh more consistent usage, which is also
my birthday.
So I really like to select this date
and up until the 4th.
Here you have the flexibility so to
select any lookback period in
the last 60 days, so it's
more flexible than the recommendation.
This is actually a simple way to think about it.
This is a super set of anything
we generate for you in the recommendation.
So, recommendation is a good
starting point for you to see like what is available,
but then you can go to the analyzer and really modify
many things and
have a lot of simulations. So in this case I'm
gonna select 28 until the 4th.
Um, um, the next selection here is
the recommendation
where it finds the max savings
water line or I can also do custom.
Custom, I can enter any number, so
maybe the water line mark is $10
I can uh enter $5.
So let's start with uh
the recommended amount.
Now, since I clicked on this, what it does
in the background, it takes every
hour in my lookback period,
it collects all the services that are eligible
for database savings plan coverage and
it starts to look for, OK,
what which dollar amount will give the maximum savings
for this type of usage.
In this case,
You can see that we went from
$2 to $28 per hour
because now I selected a short period of
time with a lot of consistent usage,
uh, and that's my estimation right now of what
I'm going to use in the future.
This will give me 14% of
savings and I can also take
a look at my coverage and utilization.
So coverage, right now,
I don't have a savings fund purchase,
so I'm actually starting from very low, from zero.
And then I'm going to
reach 100% coverage for
this purchase.
Um, you can actually go over
and see hour by hour.
There is a I I I
I can see that there's a small
amount of coverage because we did
purchase a tiny savings fund just to test that
it works. So you can see that here.
Uh, so you can see hour by hour what's the
coverage and same for utilization.
So here I see there is some
peaks and troughs in my environment
and at some point my savings plan is not gonna be
utilized,
uh, which is OK. Still have 76%
utilization.
So I can narrow it down or,
uh, or I can be I can just take
this into account. OK, this is my weekend drops.
I wanna see what I'm going to optimize with my
weekend drops since it's a yearly commitment.
In this case, I can go here,
click on custom,
and
Let's, let's do $15 and
see what, maybe I'm not ready for the max
savings commitment.
So I'm gonna click on $15
run analysis,
and now it's going to do the same thing. It's
aggregating all the hourly usage and
it's starting to apply the $15 per hour
each hour
and then then we'll see the results for that.
OK, I decreased it by 50%.
So now I see that
I have more
on-demand uncovered, so the red part
is on-demand and I have some coverage
which is the blue area.
If I click on coverage,
I'll see that now I'm not at 100%
coverage anymore. I actually reduced
it to
an average of 65%
coverage
and maybe that's a good start for me. I, I just
wanna purchase one and then I'm gonna go with
my coverage over time as
I see my usage grow and I'm getting more
comfortable with savings plan purchases.
Lastly, the utilization
is going to be 7 79%. Again,
because we did testing, we have a lot of ups and downs.
Usually when uh for customer
environments,
you will see more steady usage for
database services.
So that's how you're going after you
run a few simulations with all these options, you
can add it to the cart and
continue to purchase the savings plan.
After you purchase the savings plan, you can
also go over here.
You have utilization report and coverage
report. In utilization report,
I want to show you exactly how to find the database
utilization.
So once you go over here, you will click
on savings plan type and
you will select database.
Apply.
In this case, we have a very tiny purchase and
it's 100% utilized
and I have more details down below
on how exactly each of
the database savings plan is utilized.
So that after you purchase, you can track
your utilization.
Um, when we look at the customer
environments, many times it's 100% or 99%
if you have a little bit of uh um
going down over the weekend.
And you can also click on coverage report.
Over here, when you click on service,
you need to uh select all the database
services
and then you can
see exactly what coverage you have.
In this case, because we have a very tiny
amount of savings when purchased,
uh we have uh.
Going to look at the last 7 days.
So
It's, it's not a lot of coverage, but the cool
thing here that I can see
the coverage per,
uh, different services,
so it gives you a lot of insights of
where the savings plan is going to
cover and which services is going to cover
for you. So you track it over time and
then you go back and you start purchasing
the savings plan again.
So we just wanna, um,
We just wanna thank you all for coming today
and one last thing we wanted to talk about
before we end the session is just to
thank you all for the feedback you give us as we
build new fin ops tools and cost optimization
features.
We use that feedback
that you send your TAMMs and log as
product feature requests in our roadmap
planning and as we plan out the next
set of launches and features we do.
That feedback is really crucial for us to make
sure we can help you optimize your AWS spend
as effectively as possible
and honestly it's a really fun job because
we get to come to reinvent and
other conferences like FinOps X
and places and bring a lot of new free
savings tools.
Um, I, I think we have maybe one some
of the best jobs in the world that we get to build tools
to help you save money, so it's a lot of fun.
But it really depends on quality feedback
from all of you as you look at your cost
and as you implement your own cost optimization
programs to let us know how we can serve you better.
So please provide feedback.
We put an email alias up here on the
screen for you if you would like to give us feedback
on any of our products, tools,
or experiences you have, feel free to just
reach out and let us know.
We love talking to customers. It's
the highlight of our day as as we go
through product management activities
and
thank you also on behalf of all of
the developers and engineers back home
that work tirelessly on all of these features.
The road and lead up to reinvent is
very difficult sometimes as we have to scramble
to get savings plans working and
everything and. There's a lot of people behind the
scenes that come together to pull
this together,
especially across so many different service teams. So
on behalf of all of those engineers, thank you
so much.
Um, your usage of these tools validates
and is rewarding for us as we
see savings roll in and usage for
these products and tools, so.
Thank you so much and again we'll be available
afterwards for questions uh
if you'd like to stay after and learn
more about any of these services or Bonnie's
story about
how they implemented and uh
really move the needle on saving 27%
off of their cloud bill, really exciting story.
So thank you all.